Data Scientists,
Machine Learning and AI Experts
are the most sought-after professionals
in the Silicon Valley and the world.
Do you know what they
have in commom?
They all know Python.
Udacity created a quick course
for learning Python programming,
with an emphasis
on Data Analysis.
Python is a simple
and objective language.
It's easy to code
and easy to learn.
It allows you to build
robust, high-level solutions.
That's why companies like
Google, Facebook,
Spotify and Netflix
use Python
to create products,
insights and new businesses.
Today, it is the most used language
in the top universities for learning programming.
It's the 5th most popular language
among programmers
and the preference
in the Data Science market.
In the Data Foundations I
Nanodegree program
you'll not only
learn the basics of Python,
such as structure, variables,
conditionals, loops,
but also everything on the
Data Analysis libraries,
which enables you
to do Data Science.
What makes
this project special
is that you'll use everything
you'll learn in a real project
and you'll get feedback
from an expert,
explaining what's good
and what needs improvement.
All this practical knowledge
will make a real impact on your career.
Sometimes we're so used
to doing repetitive tasks
that we forget that
programming and tech are there
to help our everyday jobs.
Python is perfect
for making analyses
in a quick and precise way.
Say goodbye to spreadsheets
and to the hours spent with Excel.
Sign up for our Data Foundations I
Nanodegree program
and take your first steps into the world
of Data Science, Machine Learning
and Artificial Intelligence.
DATA SCIENCE FOUNDATIONS I
PYTHON FOR DATA ANALYSIS